it's my pleasure to have Aaron room give
us more of a local picture
what's happening with MSM here in
Connecticut Erin thank you and good
morning I whoops well that's okay to
save time I could just say ditto but and
you can't go wrong with the national
data but i do want to provide a few
numbers describing what's happening here
in connecticut now and my assignment is
to focus mainly on MSM trends over the
past few years but hiv/aids surveillance
has been conducted in in connecticut
since the early 80s in almost 20,000
cases have been reported since then with
almost half of them having died the
importance here is that about
twenty-five percent of cases that have
been reported in Connecticut have been
in MSM about 2,700 cases this breakdown
there's a couple here one is by race
ethnicity one by age group you can see
that by race ethnicity about two-thirds
of cases are white with about twenty
percent black and twenty percent
Hispanic and then by age about
three-quarters of cases are over the age
of 40 so this is primarily middle age
group of people and then very small
percentages under the age of 20 and then
somewhat larger percentages between 20
and 40 so predominantly hiv-positive MSM
and Connecticut are white and above the
age of 40 but not all race ethnicity
groups have the same age structure and
that's shown in the next slide and was
covered by the by Ted as well and you
can see here there are two breakdowns
one among white and one non-white the
age structures in white about fifteen
percent of cases are below the age of 40
but forty percent of cases that are
non-white are below the age of 40 and
then conversely you can see that many of
the white cases are even above the age
of 60 where very few of the non-white
cases are so these very different age
structures could have implications for
sorts of prevention interventions might
be expected to be effective in different
groups now here getting into the trends
of in MSM there's two pie charts one
shows the the bulk of cases diagnosed
between 81 and 2004 about twenty-five
percent as i said before were MSM but in
more recently diagnosed cases you can
see that almost a third or a greater of
cases have been an MSM now these are
proportions of cases so we need to take
a look at the actual numbers to see what
what the trends are and you can see here
the top line is actually a decreasing
trend in diagnosed cases in among all
people with HIV okay and what I've shown
here is itu MSM and heterosexual groups
which is a the vast majority of cases
now the individual trends are shown
below there and you can see the IDU
cases are actually accounting for the
majority of the decrease in cases and
they decreased from 400 cases to around
100 cases over this eight-year period
heterosexual cases also decreased
somewhat from around 250 cases to around
100 cases but you can see the MN MSM
cases have not decreased so they've
remained stubbornly flat over this
entire period
now this trend shows the the year of
diagnosis in among IDU heterosexual and
r MSM and this is the proportion of
cases it's the same data as we showed in
the previous slide but you can see that
because the IDU cases decreased the
proportion of cases that are MSM has
actually increased so the proportion of
cases in 2009 was forty-six percent and
that's approximately what it was the
proportion of cases that were IDU cases
at the beginning of this time period now
this is a a little more detail this is
strictly MSM cases over a period of two
thousand six to two thousand nine and
the top line is the total MSM cases that
have been diagnosed in Connecticut and
then these these other lines are
breakdowns by the red line is white and
then black Hispanic and then at the
bottom there's actually been about 15
cases of asians and others who have been
diagnosed over this time period and you
can see that where there is a suggestion
of a decrease among white MSM I don't I
don't think I'm ready to say that there
actually is that decrease because if you
look earlier than this time period to
see cases this is more like a
fluctuation and in fact if you look at
the black and Hispanic total those
numbers of cases of actually running
flat over this time period now this this
slide shows the net change in the people
living with HIV in the various risk
groups and you can see over this period
of time the people that are living with
HIV that our IDU hasn't changed okay
there's been very little change in the
number of people in that group
heterosexual has gone up by about
fourteen percent over this time period
but the number of people who are MSM has
gone up almost by a fourth or twenty
three percent now the next couple of
slides are maps of Connecticut obviously
and what's shown here is a distribution
of MSM cases by
of residents and the white towns have no
cases reported and then the lighter
green towns have one to four and you can
see if I if I advance to msn or two itu
and then go back you'll see that it'll
the distribution will leap out at you a
little bit that there are in fact many
many towns with small numbers of MSM
living in them distributed around
Connecticut whereas with IDU there's
actually half as many towns that have
one to four cases of of ITU living in
those towns now this is this is part of
the part of the national HIV incidence
study that was mentioned previously but
this is the Connecticut data and you can
see that overall as part of this study
600 people were infected with Resta
mated to be infected with HIV in 2006
and the largest proportion of those were
actually in MSM at about 180 for so
significant numbers of MSM are
continuing to be infected each year
another thing that's come up recently is
that CDC has released a prevalence
estimate of MSM and the population
saying that four percent of men above
the age of 13 are MSM and if we do some
some rough calculations we find we can
estimate that 55,000 people in men in
Connecticut are MSM and we know of those
the ones we know of 2,700 are infected
and in doing that we can do an estimate
that five percent of MSM are currently
infected with HIV and I have a bullet
here that high-risk groups within the
MSM would be expected to have much
higher rates of infection and that's and
that's certainly true as it is for other
demographic subgroups people are not
homogeneous within certain groups and of
course there are MSM that are also IDU
there are MSM with multiple sex partners
MSM with high-risk sexual behaviors of
you as you've heard so in conclusion a
data from a variety of surveillance
activities point to continue
transmission of HIV and MSM and these
systems are both
necticut and the National hiv/aids
surveillance systems the HIV incidence
project STD surveillance which are going
to hear about next as well as matches
and other interactions between the HIV
and STD surveillance systems which Heidi
will describe while a number of hiv/aids
cases in IDU has decreased the number of
newly diagnosed MSM cases has been level
over the past several years and the
number of people living with hiv/aids
who are MSM has increased by about
twenty-five percent the percentage of
non-white MSM hiv/aids cases has
increased non MSM cases tend to be
younger MSM cases are distributed
broadly across the street in both into
the state in both rural and urban areas
and significant numbers and new
estimates of MSM prevalence yield HIV
rates in MSM for the first time and and
these calculations show that HIV risk
and MSM is comparable to other high-risk
groups in Connecticut ok thank you